[Musique]
lorsqu on en rêve lucide on peut être
effectivement comme le réalisateur d'un
film dont on contrôle tous les
paramètres plus ou moins mais on va
pouvoir réaliser le scénario qu'on
souhaite des patients profitent de leurs
rêves lucides pour réaliser les
scénarios de leur rêve justement comme
voulait avoir des relations sexuelles
avec leur star préférée
on a pas mal d'anecdotes un peu
extraordinaire racontée par les patients
sur comment ils expérimentent comment
ils se transforment en animaux par
exemple sur comment ils vont expirer des
pays lointains incroyable des paysages
magnifiques
certains patients semblent avoir des
expériences vraiment extraordinaire au
cours de la brève
[Musique]
tout d'abord tenir un journal de rêve
tous les matins vous écrivez les rêves
que vous avez fait dans la nuit ça va
augmenter votre nombre de rêve et
faciliter le fait de rêves lucides
d'autres techniques sont les tests de
réalité un test de réalité c'est par
exemple vous boucher le nez pendant la
journée
si vous constatez vous n'arrivez plus à
respirer vous êtes bien dans la réalité
c'est un comportement que vous allez
ensuite peut-être répété en rêve
et lorsqu'ils veulent se produire vous
allez vous apercevoir par exemple que
vous continuez à respirer et donc vous
rendre compte qu'il s'agit d'un bref il
existe d'autres méthodes comme par
exemple ouvrir un livre
regardez une page de contenu de ce livre
détourner le regard est ensuite regarder
à nouveau le contenu du livre
si vous êtes dans la réalité la page
sera la même si vous êtes dans le rêve
comme il est impossible de manière dans
votre mémoire quelque chose d'aussi
complexe que la page entière dans livre
le continent aura changé et là vous
réaliserez que vous êtes dans un rêve
il ya certains sujets qui sans même
utiliser des techniques faune très
fréquemment des rêves lucides on sait ne
me prenez pas exactement le mécanisme
pas de facteurs génétiques a priori
identifié pour l'instant
souvent lorsque les sujets entre dans un
rêve lucide
le simple fait de savoir que c'est un
rêve au vent tu mens l'excitation que ça
va créer va provoquer un éveil rapide il
faut être un peu plus entraînés pour
arriver à se maintenir dans le rêve
éventuellement changer le court créé un
scénario ça peut faire penser au film
inception effectivement qui est un film
qui met en scène des rêveurs lucide qui
rentre dans les rêves des gens pour leur
voler des secrets
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on peut
réaliser à notre niveau en utilisant les
rêveurs lucide que nous on voit un peu
comme des agents infiltrés du rêve alors
pas pour voler des secrets industriels
dans notre cas mais pour nous apprendre
des choses sur la fonction des rêves
comment saucisses des rôles etc
les rêveurs lucide peuvent contrôler la
direction de leurs yeux lorsqu'ils son
rêve lucide ça va nous permettre de
capter ces mouvements ils vont pouvoir
réaliser en code avec leurs yeux en
général droite gauche droite gauche cote
qu'on va pouvoir capter à l'aide d'un
pays qui s'appelle un électro kg ce qui
va leur permettre de signaler en direct
le fait qu'ils sont lucides et
va ouvrir la porte à la recherche
scientifique les dernières études que
nous sommes en train de réaliser nous
avons montré qu'il était possible de
leur envoyer de notre côté des signaux à
l'intérieur du rêve qu'ils peuvent
intégrer en leur parlant ou en réalisant
une stimulation tactile par exemple 80%
de la population qui en fera au moins
une fois dans sa vie
les gens qui ont font toutes les
semaines par exemple sont plus rares
environ 2% de la population pourrait
peut-être imaginer un jour utiliser le
rêve lucide et ses bénéfices pour aider
les patients
par exemple une des choses qui nous
intéresse ce serait peut-être d'évaluer
son impact sur les troubles de l'humeur
la dépression voir comment pour agir
directement à l'intérieur du rêve pour
modifier son cerveau pour aller mieux